Tak.
Gdy patrzysz na dzisiejsze możliwości, myślę, że to
też bardzo ważne pytanie: no dobra,
jaka jest mapa drogowa? O ile
lepsze są te systemy
i o ile bardziej złożone
będą circuit'y, które będziemy w stanie wykonywać?
I do tego opracowaliśmy bardzo ważną metrykę,
zwaną quantum volume.
Czasem możesz przeczytać lub usłyszeć w popularnej prasie
o liczbie qubitów i wiesz,
traktować to jako miarę postępu.
Powiem ci wprost, że
sama liczba qubitów w maszynie to nie jest
dobra miara postępu.
Postęp trzeba mierzyć
poziomem złożoności circuit'u, który możesz wykonać.
Qubity w tych dobrych maszynach nie są dziś doskonałe
i mają błędy, które wprowadza sprzężenie
systemu ze światem zewnętrznym.
Sama moc tych qubitów —
splątanie i te właściwości —
sprawia, że są one jednocześnie potężne
i wrażliwe na interakcję
i połączenie ze światem zewnętrznym.
Musisz więc obniżać współczynnik błędów,
jednocześnie zwiększając liczbę qubitów.
I właśnie to jest tu pokazane:
naprawdę chcesz to robić — chcesz poruszać się po przekątnej.
Quantum volume to miara, która uwzględnia
obie te metryki oraz kilka kluczowych dodatkowych aspektów.